bon alors moi je fais partie de ces gens
insupportable qui pensent toujours
qu'ils ont raison et
la seule justification que c'est quand
même vachement plus simple de se balader
dans le monde est d'avoir toujours
raison
après j'ai quand même 36 ans dont je
commence à avoir beaucoup parlé beaucoup
dit bêtise très très grosse donc
forcément au bout d'un moment on
commence quand même à se remettre en
question et se dire que peut-être
peut-être des fois on n'a pas tout à
fait raison
et alors c'est un mal pour un bien parce
que je vous le cache pas c'est pas
pratique c'est beaucoup plus pratique
d'avoir toujours raison mais je pense
que c'est un bien parce que dans
l'époque actuelle je pense qu'on a
vraiment besoin de douter de ses
certitudes alors on est dans une époque
personne sait où on va mener tous
collectivement certain qu'on y va quand
même et on s'est tous aussi que ça va
pas avoir l'air d'une fête foraine
l'odeur de barbe à papa tout ça c'est
pas forcément ce qui nous attend et dans
des moments comme ça quand on regarde un
peu l'histoire on s'aperçoit que c'est
là où on se jette dans des certitudes
aveugle où on croit fermement parce
qu'en fait on est terrorisée par
l'avenir on s'accroche à des certitudes
fragile mais on s'y accroche fermement
et je pense que souvent mais c'est là où
les drames humains secret et l'humanité
a le secret de ces drames là et je pense
que plus on va s'accrocher à des
certitudes de manière aveugle
plus on aura tendance potentiellement à
faire émerger ces ces drames là et je
pense que le doute de ses certitudes et
la compréhension aussi de l'origine des
certitudes des autres c'est un moyen de
prévention et d'atténuation
potentiellement de ces drames humains
pour moi j'aimerais juste aujourd'hui
vous présenter deux histoires deux
expériences de pensée qui moi me font
terriblement douter de mes certitudes
parce que je pense que ça peut être
utile ça a été utile à moi je suis
certain que ça peut être utile à
d'autres notamment s'ils sont touchés
par ce syndrome insupportable d'avoir la
certitude d'avoir souvent très raison
imaginons alors un monde on est tous
hyper heureux et alors tous hyper
heureux à notre manière alors que six
mois mon kiff c'est lire des livres tout
le temps j'ai droit livre délivre tout
le temps si vous votre qui sait faire du
vélo à toute allure vous pourrez faire
ça et c dont là qui sait qui est chaud
pour ce problème politique là jean loup
bah c'est bien vous n'êtes pas trop
chaud parce que vous avez bien compris
que les politiques de base faut pas non
plus croire aux promesses et puis parce
qu'en fait ça il ya toujours un
défaut dans ce set conception du bonheur
c'est que ben forcément si moi mon
bonheur ça passe par tabasser tous mes
voisins je vais avoir du mal à trouver
autant de voisins dont le bonnart va
être de se faire tabasser par mois on a
ce truc là où on sent bien que il ya un
petit à petit dans le pâté comme
certains disent je n'oserais pas et en
fait on se dit ok faisons abstraction
abstraction de ça si quand même moi je
pouvais être heureux à ma manière sans
causer de tort à personne c'est dire
qu'en gros on me dit tu vas être
parfaitement heureux suivante à manière
de vouloir être heureux et on te
garantis que ça ne causera de tort à
personne
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est attractif mais c'est attractif
jusqu'à ce qu'on regarde la vidéo de
monsieur fille qui reprend c'est la
première histoire donc c'est une vidéo
de monsieur fille qui youtuber que vous
peut râler c'est très bien qui reprend
une expérience de pensée de robert
nozick et qui est très simple en gros
imaginez que des extraterrestres arrive
sur terre et nous propose un peu ce que
vous est proposé c'est à dire qu'en gros
il vous dit on va proposer à tout le
monde un bonheur absolu à sa manière
dont là on est tous bouillant dans les
extraterrestres lundi balesi qu'on fait
et c'est
donc les extraterrestres nous amène dans
une salle et dans la salle au fond il ya
des sarcophages numérique et 10 belles
c'est très simple dès que vous vous
branchez à ces machines vous vivre vous
vivrez d'un monde simulés mais vous en
rendrez pas content parce que vous
révéré comme tous les matins et en fait
vous aurez vraiment la vie parfaite dire
que vous vivrez dans la monde simuler
toujours avec vos amis simuler qui
feront exactement ce que vous avez envie
de faire qui vous parleront exactement
comme vous avez envie qu'on vous parle
avec toute la cnv du monde et c'est donc
ça sera vraiment que parfait et et vous
vivrez une expérience de bonheur total
alors là il ya peut-être un petit truc
vous pouvez vous dire oui mais moi si je
me branche ça veut dire que quelque part
je laisse mes proches et du coup j'ai
causé du tort à mes proches non vos
proches vous dise écoute city va on se
branche et si tu y vas pas on se
branchent pas donc en fait si vous avez
ce choix là vous pouvez pas causer de
tort à personne parce que vous le ne
laisser personne sur le carreau et s'il
se branchent vos amis y vivront avec la
version simulé de vous qui fera
exactement ce que eux ont envie que vous
fassiez dans un monde complètement idéal
et dont la question aller simple est ce
que vous prenez plutôt la pilule rouge
avec la véritable réalité donc la chance
d'un véritable bonheur véritable mais
aussi la certitude de connaître des
guerres des famines des génocides des
malheurs et des souffrances parce que
vous l'a dit la barbe à papa c'est pas
forcément pour les 40 ans qui arrive ou
alors l'illusion d'une réalité mais
aussi la certitude d'un bonheur absolu à
gaza c est ce que vous prenez la pilule
rouge où la pilule bleue qui épie le
rouge
et qui est pilule bleue
alors quelques uns puis le bleu
quelques-uns son pull rouge beaucoup son
pull rouge le projecteur a beau être
gros je vois
est en fait cette expérience de pensée
manche qu'elle est forte parce que quel
que soit ce que vous
pensez est-ce que vous décidez vous
rendez compte qu'en fait il ya autre
chose que juste le bonheur qui
intervient dans votre calcul sinon vous
auriez pas choisi de continuer à évoluer
dans le monde actuel et de risquer de
potentiel souffrance mais en gros c'est
très simple mais quand on a une question
d'ordre moral vous avez vos informations
sur le monde vous avez vos croyances vos
valeurs et on a parlé tout à l'heure
c'est vrai qu'entre la sécurité et la
liberté on a tous des arbitrages
différent on a pu le voir pendant les
deux dernières années et il ya aucun
arbitrage qui est foncièrement bon
foncièrement mauvais c d arbitrage
différent qui sont les vôtres et or ont
fait un calcul qui donne une réponse qui
est soit l'une sur l'autre donc moi ma
réponse a priori quand j'ai fait de
l'essence c'était la pilule rouge est en
fête est ce que c'est en poste en
question c'est que ça met à jour le fait
que ma mosaïque de valeur elle est
extrêmement complexe
et s'impose aussi la question de est-ce
qu'elle est universelle cette mosaïque
de valeur à ce qu'ils on devrait tendre
vers une mosaïque de valeur avec tous
des critères et des arbitrages qui sont
les mêmes est ce que si valeur elles
sont à très fragile et aussi d'où elles
viennent et sur ça j'ai une autre
histoire donc c'est la deuxième que je
trouve très forte et qui est illustrée
dans ce roman alors c'est le meilleur
des mondes en français dans le secret
qui est vraiment alors pour ceux qui
n'ont pas lu le roman je le recommande
et je vais faire jusque le contexte donc
le contexte c'est vous avez un ordre
mondial où tout le monde est
conditionnée hypnotisé depuis même le
stade embryonnaire pour être hyper
heureux de la condition et de la place
dans la société que la personne doit
occuper donc c'est comme si on était
tous conditionnés à être parfaitement
satisfaits de l'expérience de vie qu'on
allait revoir et gens qui sont
conditionnés mais avec qui ça n'a pas
trop marché on les met dans des parcs à
sauvage et voilà ils sont dans leurs
petites zones et ils font leurs trucs et
l'ordre mondial fonctionne très très
bien
et en gros le climax le point culminant
du bouquin c'est le dialogue entre le
président de l'ordre mondial qui
s'appelle mustapha meunier et john le
sauvage qui comme son nom l'indiqué
était plutôt dans les parcs
et euro se donne le sauvage il a voulu
arriver dans les terres mondial il a
voulu
générer une révolution vous n'êtes pas
vraiment heureux bon il s'est pris un
mur parce que essayer de faire une
révolution avait des gens qui se sentent
parfaitement heureux c'est pas le projet
révolutionnaire le plus pratique et
mustapha meunier quand même très
pédagogue le prend entre deux yeux une
fois capturés et si de lui expliquer
pourquoi c'est ça ça ça veut rien dire
son truc il lui dit ici au mondial vous
est conditionnée de telle sorte que vous
ne pouvez vous empêcher de faire ce que
vous avez à faire est ce que vous avez à
faire est dans l'ensemble six agréable
on laisse le libre jeu un si grand
nombre de vos impulsions naturel qu'il
n'ya véritablement pas de tentations
auxquelles il faille résister et si
jamais par quelques malchances il se
produisait d'une façon ou d'une autre
quelque chose de désagréable
eh bien il ya toujours le sommet qui
vous permet de prendre congé et de vous
évader de la réalité alors johnny
devient fou quand on entend ça parce que
pour lui c'est pas du tout comme ça que
ça marche et il lui hurle dessus mais
les larmes sont nécessaires et pau pour
pour nous sa famille j'ai nommé les
larmes étaient nécessaires peut-être
avant dans un autre contexte dans une
autre organisation
mais maintenant elles sont en rien
nécessaire parce que là où il y à des
guerres il lui répond là où il ya des
serments de fidélité multiples divisée
là où il ya des tentations auxquelles on
doit résister des objets d'amour pour
lesquels il faut combattre ou qu'il faut
défendre là manifestement la noblesse et
l'héroïsme ont un sens mais il n'y a pas
de guerre de nos jours et en fait ce
qu'on peut lui accorder que
effectivement l'héroïsme émerge d'un
contexte où l'héroïsme a été utile
toutes les valeurs en fait elles
émergent de contexte où ces valeurs là
on aurait été utile
et eux viennent de contexte tellement
différent entre john le sauvage et
mustapha meunier qu'en fait ils peuvent
jamais tombés d'accord sur quelles sont
les bonnes valeurs vu que les contextes
dans lesquels ils ont grandi et d'où ont
émergé ces systèmes de valeurs là sont
trop différents pour qu'ils s'accordent
et donc john le sauvage il prend ce mur
là il n'arrive pas à comprendre parce
que lui forcément ces valeurs là sont
les bonnes il arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi ils trouvent de l'apathie chez
les gens et il n'arrive pas à générer
cette révolution et et du coup il a un
peu bu dix mille moi je n'en veux pas du
confort je veux dieu je veux de la
poésie je veux du danger véritable je
veux la liberté je veux de la bonté je
veux du péché et ce à quoi nous ça va
venir répond reformule résume à sa sauce
de cette manière en somme vous réclamer
le droit d'être malheureux
sans parler du droit d'avoir la syphilis
et le cancer du droit d'avoir trop peu à
manger du droit d'avoir des poux du
droit de vivre dans l'appréhension
constante de ce qui pourra se produire
demain du droit d'attraper la typhoïde
du droit d'être torturés par des
douleurs indicibles de toutes sortes et
john répond oui je les réclames tout et
mustapha répond on vous les donne avec
grand coeur
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'effectivement on va vouloir où on va
vouloir de l'héroïsme même si a pas
besoin d'héroïsme très bien mais moi
dans la société actuelle je me dis qu'on
va vouloir par exemple de
l'individualisme
même si l'individualisme aujourd'hui
n'est plus soutenable en terme d'énergie
et de ressources on a plus peut-être
l'énergie et les ressources ou le climat
pour rouler tous en voiture tous seuls
dans notre voiture etc et en rose que ce
que ça souligne c'est le fait que les
valeurs comporte c'est toujours des
valeurs qui ont émergé de contexte passé
on a toujours un temps de retard parce
que les valeurs comporte naturellement
ce sont les valeurs qui ont émergé de
contexte dans lequel les communautés
dont on est issu de nos parents nous
culture notre classe sociale peut être
cédée contexte en tous les cas passés et
en fait ce que souligne ce roman ce
dialogue en particulier c'est pas que
une dystopie c'est la difficulté la
difficulté même de l'utopie parce que le
monde il est tellement changeant que
forcément il va générer des valeurs qui
vont changer et les valeurs en changeant
elles vont aussi changer nos
comportements qui vont de nouveau
changer le monde et c'est une recherche
constante de cet équilibre une boucle
infinie de changement de valeur parce
que dès qu'on sera satisfait des valeurs
en fait on changera le monde émergera de
ce nouveau monde de nouvelles valeurs et
donc c'est une boucle infinie dans le
temps mais c'est une boucle infinie
aussi géographiquement parce que deux
contextes différents de climats
différents de pays différents
d'histoires différentes vont
nécessairement émerger des valeurs qui
va différentes alors bien sûr elles sont
massivement commune c'est ça qu'on va
appeler les valeurs universelles parce
que quand même les contextes qu'a
traversée la plupart de l'humanité sont
massivement les mêmes la condition
humaine
conçois qu'on ait vécu il ya 2000 ans ou
aujourd'hui ça reste la condition
humaine
mais la question que moi je me pose du
coup c'est mais qui a raison
quelles sont les bonnes valeurs et en
quoi moi mes valeurs que je défends
âprement seront les bonnes forcément je
vais tenter une petite réponse de
normand mais en gros personne et tout le
monde à la fois
tout le monde a raison parce que tout le
monde porte en lui une réponse possible
aux contextes dont il est issu
personne n'a raison parce qu'en fait
comme on a tous un temps de retard
forcément personne aujourd'hui à le
système de valeurs qui correspond aux
enjeux climatiques et énergétiques
sociaux actuels
encore une fois l'individualisme est une
bonne illustration de sang le contexte
actuel il favorise pas je pense un
individualisme on est tous dans la même
barque climatique et ce nouveau contexte
à va faire émerger doit faire émerger
des valeurs qui sont pas encore ou qu'on
incarne pas encore
et
c'est ça moi que j'essaie de me dire ces
histoires c'est ça qu'elle me dise c'est
évidemment il faut douter de mes valeurs
de mes croyances syndicats mais aussi je
pense qu'il faut comprendre que on a
tous un temps de retard et que plutôt
que de me battre pour des valeurs dont
je suis issue et qui ont répandu aux
enjeux de contexte passé est-ce que je
peux pas à réfléchir à quelles seraient
les valeurs que je veux défendre
aujourd'hui et qui correspondent pas aux
enjeux du passé mais actuel ou voire de
demain
et plutôt que de voir des valeurs
différentes qui s'opposent moi j'en s'il
faut voir ça comme une immense
bibliothèque de connaissances
tout ça c'est des valeurs qui ont
correspondu à des thèmes passer à des
contextes passé donc chacun de nous est
une sorte de livre ambulant avec une
réponse spécifique au contexte dont il
est issu
et vraiment c'est le rappelle que je
cherche à me faire à chaque fois que
quelqu'un qui est vraiment un désaccord
et moi je me dis bah c'est une partie de
la solution et je pense que chaque
vision du monde chaque culture chaque
fonctionnement à des éléments de réponse
au contexte qui vont arriver mais il ya
aucune personne n'y a aucune culture qui
a tous les éléments de réponse merci
[Applaudissements]